what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and everything relating to
the marvel cinematic universe i'm your
host warren thompson and we have a lot
of marvel news to talk about today that
has happened over the past couple of
days some of the biggest pieces of news
being jaden smith will smith's son might
have been cast to play miles morales in
the mcu it sure does seem that way based
off of what will smith has said doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness is
going back for reshoots right before the
movie is coming out hopefully this isn't
that bad of news and a producer for
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness has commented on the illuminati
and this is kind of confusing to some
people so i'll break down what he said
what it means and why you shouldn't
actually panic that much we'll break
everything down in this video and of
course if you're new and you love marvel
be sure to subscribe so you don't miss
out on any of the latest marvel videos
so let's first start with the big news
that jaden smith could have been cast as
miles morales in the mcu now most people
know jaden smith as will smith's son
jaden has acted in several different
projects mostly known for the karate kid
acting with his father in the pursuit of
happiness and after earth and he's been
in other big movies like the day the
earth stood still so he does have a lot
of acting experience and a huge
important factor about this is that he
actually kind of fits the bill when it
comes to playing miles morales in fact
he's a pretty big fan cast from the
marvel audience and as of right now it
kind of looks like he may have already
been cast as miles morales let's take a
look at what will smith had to say about
an upcoming role that his son jaden
smith is preparing for in a recent
interview with pop time dot space this
is what will smith had to say about this
role that his son is training for at the
moment he said my son is preparing
himself physically and mentally to take
the place of one of the characters who
will make history for the first time in
the saga of a movie that many already
know and ask for now a lot of people are
really thinking that this is going to be
a live action version of miles morales
especially if you consider what will
smith is saying a character who was
going to make history for the first time
in the saga of a movie so for the first
time in history of asaga that means this
saga has already been going on for some
time now but his character is going to
make history in the saga meaning it's
going to be very very different now of
course all the spider-man that we've had
so far live action are peter parker and
of course i'm talking about movies not
the shows like japanese spider-man so
everyone we've had so far is peter
parker and everyone we've had so far is
a white male coming in as the first
black and puerto rican spider-man miles
morales would certainly make history
especially on the big screen live action
where we haven't seen that yet of course
we've seen him in spider-man into the
spider-verse and upcoming in spider-man
across the spider-verse but never
live-action plus not to mention we did
just get a miles morales reference in
spider-man no way home jamie foxx's
elektra says there's gotta be a black
spider-man out there somewhere in which
andrew garfield spider-man just nods and
smiles this is definitely an easter egg
for miles morales and i do think marvel
would be pretty foolish to not at least
start to introduce miles morales in the
mcu for this final spider-man trilogy
with tom holland at least we assume it's
tom holland's final trilogy that is not
confirmed though but spider-man no way
home set up feast the organization that
miles morales volunteers at aunt may was
obviously a huge part of that so it
would make sense that in the next
spider-man films peter parker would
volunteer as well in commemoration of
aunt may so the pieces are there and
will smith says that his son is
preparing mentally but also physically
now obviously the role of miles morales
or any spider-man is going to be a
physically demanding role especially if
you're somebody like tom holland who
does do some of his own stunts obviously
he has a stunt team for the big ones but
tom holland had been doing gymnastics
since he was a little kid so it would
make sense that the studio would want
somebody like that for miles morales now
as far as the casting is concerned i
think it's okay i typically trust marvel
studios with their casting choices
because they've hit the nail on the head
every time so far i'm not a huge jaden
smith fan from the movies that he's been
in but a lot can happen over the years
and if he has been cast as miles morales
i'm certainly willing to give him a
chance and i'm definitely willing to
trust marvel studios but before we dive
into doctor strange let me know what you
think about this casting choice down
below if he actually is indeed going to
be miles morales and has been cast
already now moving on to doctor strange
in the multiverse of madness now one of
the best scenes that we've seen so far
in the trailer for doctor strange is
that illuminati scene and now one of the
producers of the film has kind of opened
up about that scene and has kind of
confirmed a suspicion that we've had for
a long time now in an interview with
empire magazine producer richie palmer
was asked about that mysterious voice in
multiverse of madness empire says it's
not so mysterious for those who have
seen the x-men movies in which richie
palmer replied with are you sure you saw
what you saw quoting the first x-men
movie he then said there are infinite
versions of these characters and just
because you may have heard something
familiar doesn't mean it's someone you
have seen before and if he is telling
the truth about this this means that the
professor xavier that we hear in this
shot in the trailer isn't most likely
the same professor x that we saw in the
original x-men films or logan he is most
likely a variant of professor xavier
that we've never seen before
we should tell him the truth empire then
told him it's thought that some of the
biggest names in hollywood might show up
in some of these roles speaking about
the illuminati then they ask could we
have some super secret ultra high
profile variants on our hands in which
the producer replied i would love to see
tony again but some rumors are just
rumors i will say that i love the
illuminati but if we ever introduce the
illuminati in the future it might be
more mcu driven and have some more ties
to our characters in the mcu versus just
replicating what's in the comics now
this is very clever wording because he's
technically not admitting that that's
the illuminati we see in the trailer but
of course we know it is it is literally
a council of superheroes and that is
literally professor xavier's voice that
we heard but what he's basically stating
here is that yes indeed this is a
multiversal variant illuminati not an
illuminati made up of the main
characters from our main timeline and
he's basically stating when that does
happen in our main timeline in the mcu
it's not essentially going to be the
original lineup from the comics now also
of course the producer is not going to
straight up come out and say yes tony
stark is returning he absolutely cannot
do that so of course he's going to play
coy about it so just because he said
this doesn't mean that he's not showing
up who will show up who knows but i'm
certainly very very excited to see and
i'm very curious who you want to see up
here in the illuminati and to top it all
off it looks like there are some more
reshoots happening now we've already had
massive delays due to the pandemic and a
few more delays that have happened at
the end of last year and early this year
we don't have the trailer for thor love
and thunder yet and it's getting really
really close but we also know that the
movie isn't finished yet reshoots are
about to take place in a couple of weeks
and now apparently the same thing is
happening with doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness and this is coming
from benedict cumberbatch doctor strange
himself dicks look not all of us can
live in la all the time okay
but i i'm yeah i've been having a very
nice time now doing research with doctor
strange oh he hasn't been doing it
now keep in mind the premiere date for
the movie has already been set and the
official release date for doctor strange
and the multiverse of madness has been
pushed back several times now i know a
lot of people have been messaging me and
panicking about what benedict said in
this interview but fortunately i think
we're way too close to the actual
release date and the movie premiere for
any type of rescheduling to happen just
keep this in the back of your mind
avengers in-game and infinity war
weren't finished until right before the
premiere basically the studio is going
to work non-stop until the movie
basically comes out to make it the best
that they can so i'm really not thinking
that we have to worry too much about
these reshoots if anything it's actually
a good thing they're trying to make the
movie better and get the scenes just
right so no need to panic but let me
know what you think about what the
producer said about the illuminati and
do you like this casting choice jaden
smith for miles morales if this has
indeed happened let me know your
thoughts in the comments down below
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest news for live updates you
can follow me on instagram and twitter
and as always thank you all so much for
watching woof